oh you think you're real scary huh
I'll show you scared
[Music]
so we've been playing tons of Red Dead
Redemption in the office there's gonna
be a lot of people out there that
haven't played a Red Dead game in the
series but GTA 5 was obviously a huge
huge game so this is kind of geared at
people who have played a lot of GTA 5
maybe not played Red Dead before all the
reasons why we think people should make
the jump we're gonna try to sell Red
Dead to you using GTA 5's there's like a
stopping point or you know reference
point really because there's obviously a
lot of similarities but also a plethora
of differences but they marry well
together and that you've played both I'm
gonna start talking about the world of
the game how do you think they compare
which do you prefer that the two vastly
different settings that are done a
similar style so GTA 5 is a lot more
recognizable to us as a familiar place
but yeah that's it's set in like a mock
California Los Angeles location and it's
it's a big parody on the real thing
basically yeah
so it does poke fun at things that are
currently happening in the world or were
happening at that time that GTA was made
where as Red Dead is less of that and it
feels more realistic would you say yeah
but the thing that I've really loved
about Red Dead so far it's an avenue or
a medium for drama or as I feel that GTA
5 world is a medium for comedy the
things that you see out in the world
like the piss washer beer in GTA 5
there's there's less of that in Red Dead
there's more there's more humanity
are you doing boy get that back up again
right now it's odd because they both
feel very similar but the tone of the
world and the setting is is it's quite
polar like you're saying the gta5 being
approximation of California it's very
recognizable and it's it's an enjoyable
place to be but I've loved my time in
red debt so much more because it's a
more beautiful place to be it's a more
human place to be a more chilled out
place as well red dead
yeah well depending where you go roads
is a bit of a weird place yeah but like
GTA I felt like you can do side
activities like play golf or you know
have fun in the world but it felt more
stressful
whereas Red Dead you can just go out
into the countryside all by yourself and
yeah you may have a bounty on your head
but you can go fishing you can go
hunting wildlife you can go admire the
beautiful landscapes it felt it feels
like more going on the holiday
whereas GTA to me just felt a bit like
this is this is real the world feels a
bit more oppressive in that it everyone
hates you and it's people are not very
nice yeah people like that in Red Dead
but it also has on the flipside nice
people and you can do nice things
in a way I feel like GTA 5 is a little
more slapstick mmm if you mount the curb
in your car and start mowing down
pedestrians it'll cause you some trouble
in the short term but it feels quite
inconsequential which is good for GTA 5
it's it feels like it needs that
slapstick it has its humor and it has
the kind of over-the-top violence to you
know show off its mechanics and its
style and that's that's that's GTA
that's great and I've loved that series
but Red Dead I'm currently working on a
feature now that is about me being a
virtual tourist in Red Dead and that's
my favorite thing about the world so far
as its it's so deep and so detailed and
so amazing and so beautiful that it's
almost allowing me to you know
experience that time period in that area
in a way that would be impossible before
this is really the reddit Red Dead is
the closest approximation of visiting
that time period that I think we we ever
had in movies books video games ever and
that's like it's been astounding to me
come lend a hand here go ahead and color
your mama quit that their jokes got mean
friends believe me
let's talk about characters Grand Theft
Auto 5 had three that you could switch
between yeah Red Dead Redemption has
just one character Arthur Morgan how he
finding him so far I actually prefer
going to like the single protagonist
style because it's allowed me to get to
know our third a much more intimate way
the character feels a bit more fleshed
out than Franklin Trevor and Michael did
in GTA 5 I found myself really kind of
becoming attached to not only Arthur but
the surrounding characters of his gang
it's been really cool to see those
fleshed out more in this in this
iteration of the game even my horse like
I bonded with my horse which I did not
expect
even's the point of the way I play it I
think the honor system plays in so my
actions in the world are having a
reaction from NPCs there was a moment
when I caused some trouble in Valentine
that gave me a bounty I paid off the
bounty went back and then everyone was a
bit wary of me that was I was really
cool to see because again is that that
direct connection to the character and
the people around him
we run far worse than you out of town
before oh come on man someone throws a
punch you punched back don't bother
pretending different rocks are very good
at having dialogue that does react to
your character and the characters around
you the way they talk to you it's like
being a little family isn't it well you
know camp it's actually quite nice to
just go up in the morning do it chores
yes - yeah it's it's quite nice to be a
part of that and everyone's of reacts
differently to you and their characters
seem to be developing individually you
know - what else is happening in the
camp what's wrong god you'd be happy to
be off that Mound the bonus of gta5 is
like I said there was three polarizing
stories they played differently they
were seeing the world from a different
point of view that was Michael who was
having like family troubles and
financial troubles Trevor who was the
loose cannon who was kind of unhinged
and then Franklin who was trying to make
it
named for himself and better himself and
he was kind of being dragged back by his
yes haircut maybe you got rid of though
years haircut you got you get some
[ __ ] on your dick but I found
although the characters started off
quite different in GTA and actually I
found using like Trevor as an outlet for
all the classic TTA all the bad stuff as
when you started like getting a five
star wanted yeah you're like I want to
let loose I'm gonna switch to Trevor
cause mayhem and then go back to Michael
or Franklin and do more civilized they
get more grounded but by the end of the
game it felt like that didn't make much
difference and the three characters were
all hyper violent and they became you
know just interchangeable for me whereas
I think Red Dead it has a really solid
main character who you're invested in
and you're constantly reminded of how
they feel in that world and their wants
and needs in relation to the rest of the
people that they're surrounded by see I
feel like your point to GTA 5 and I
couldn't I totally understand that this
accommodating story but I feel like that
was because Franklin was learning from
Michael and Trevor was stressing Michael
outs they kind of became you know they
took elements from each other though
alright hate your homie I'm someone you
want to impress like I said before it
has been really cool to bond with such a
well-written well fleshed out character
that is not only built up and like
create a super well-written super well
but also allows me to actually project a
little bit of myself onto that character
I think there's still that contrast
though where you're being a good person
you're you know not hustling people
you're going hunting your mind you're
growing business then you're thrown into
a story mission where you're killing a
whole town full of lawmen yeah that's
like oh yeah I am still playing Red Dead
Redemption I'm not in this fantasy well
that's it my utopia where I can do what
I want and have fun it's it's still
quite violent and those things still you
are forced down a certain track I think
it's chaotic good any yes yeah catechin
Arthur
so in terms of actually playing the game
if you played GTA 5 you can pick up a
controller and be instantly familiar
with the with the red dead controls they
play pretty much similar in the terms of
menus and running and shooting they're
very very similar but what you can do in
the world and the pacing and the the
environment and just experience are
actually very different
yeah Grand Theft Auto is this mad crazy
adrenaline fueled fast paced massacre
through a city and a country that we we
know and it's quite a contrast when you
start playing Red Dead and you're like
oh actually I need to take things a bit
it's a much slower burner yeah and even
down to like how you get around like
riding a horse versus driving a sports
car personally I find the driving of GTA
still a lot more fun and found those
moments between missions and traversing
the world a bit more exciting but yeah
would you say like Red Dead just feels a
lot more slow-paced and how did that
yeah do you approach to the game it's
got they've both got kind of the most
that can be quite cathartic right like
you were saying GTA 5's like the intense
stress reliever
whereas Red Dead Redemption - it's kind
of like a nice relaxed sort of game I
feel towards the end of GTA 5 as I'm
just gonna call the taxi and get to I
need to go on a fast travel but I've I
feel like fast traveling in Red Dead
Redemption - you're kind of missing out
on one of the the best parts of it which
is that amazing amazing world and you
come across such bizarre things just out
on your travels in Red Dead Redemption
seeing someone's side of the road who
needs help or someone shouting at you as
you as you go past whereas GTA 5 you
could jump in your car like
pedal-to-the-metal
crank the rate you on you're gonna I
feel that that means you're gonna miss a
lot of yeah going just flying by
building yeah obviously the Traverse the
world's a one-element gunplay is also a
huge one again they play very different
very similarly in the way that they aim
the way they control but because of just
the time its setting the gunplay in Red
Dead is much more deliberate I feel and
you'll find yourself not actually having
as many gunfights
as you do in GTA 5 it's much more
grounded in the gunplay mechanics and
the fact that you have like machine gun
and sniper rifles and rocket launchers
feels very different there's much more
mechanical in that your your gun needs
to be maintained yeah yeah after it and
while you still have that sort of jump
out of cover and pop to your target that
that gunplay is quite similar but then
Deadeye which was my favorite thing from
the last Red Dead Redemption game is
back and it's all tied to your cause
which I find a bit tricky to look after
what do you think about the core system
I really like the core system cuz it
feels it's another element of me
connecting with Arthas it feels like
he's getting stronger
as I'm experiencing more of the game but
again it's it's it's that element of
realism that is it's forced upon but
again not in an unwelcomed way it's
everything every system in Red Dead has
been implemented and presents to you in
a very natural way I feel yeah these
these these mechanics is just it's not
good to the point where they feel
unwelcome it's just a nice little tidbit
to kind of attach you to the game a
little more and think about the way
you're playing a little more
more you know like you say deliberate a
little more human and that's that's
really been my favorite part about Red
Dead - that's wholly agree I think the
role playing is something I'm doing way
more in red then yeah and I make sure
Arthur goes to bed and he has a bath and
he says yes and it's I never really
thought about this in GTA but in Red
Dead I want to take care of Arthur as if
he was me yeah keep my my beard nice and
tidy
you know if he's if he's done a big
heist I'll take him out and buy him a
new hat she deserves the best
treat yourself are so if you've played
grand theft auto 5 and you probably have
there's a lot to enjoy in Red Dead
Redemption Dave what would you say like
the big things that GTA fans are gonna
go out of red dead it's interesting
because there's a lot of GTA fans that
have actually never played a Red Dead
game but if you want that amazing level
of Rockstar polish and attention to
detail the amazing writing that have
been in both games you're gonna get that
but you're also going to get a much more
human story you're going to get
something that's a bit more dramatic a
bit more deliberate a bit of a slower
paced a much wider world with with a lot
more to experience it's two really
insanely polished game but I can't put
down in in a way that's like really
surprised me it's definitely a game that
you've got a sort of take slowly and
appreciate and just let yourself take
your time with it enjoy it yeah it's a
game that needs respecting and I think
it's respectful of your time as well
thanks for the sit down for a few hours
and and enjoy it so no doubt you've got
your own interesting stories about Red
Dead that we would love to hear and
especially if this is your first Red
Dead game like please let us know what
you think of it I'd really love to hear
your point of view you can leave that in
the comment section below or you can
find me on Twitter I am at a regular
Dave and Bill is at the quiff is dead he
did a really good read tweet of the day
from cinematic mode so at the very least
you should go check that out but for
everything else Red Dead Redemption to
stay tuned to games but partner
[Music]